martin ont fait la course plus beau
surtout pleurs didon j'en connais un qui
al air chargé à bloc mais j'ai aucune
chose qu'on doit partir
[Musique]
salut les copains je venais vous
prévenir que j'allais partir quelques
temps je retourne dans l'ess pour le
mariage le masseur être un peu comment
ça ta soeur paola ça retourne le cerveau
ça doit faire des siennes le que tu ne
l'as pas je pourrais peut-être
d'accompagner les mains c'est une petite
virée entre copains il ya un milliard de
choses à voir
avec un léger petit arrière-goût de
danger
oh je crois pas
je crois que c'est le début d'une belle
aventure tu as tout à fait raison
mandicourt des petites routes france
alors c'est trop
qu'on se fasse de nouveau ça vous
comptez aller
donc je me nettoie la carrosserie
waouh
tu brille de mille feux comment suis-je
tu étais déjà parfait tel que tu étais
mais que vois-je demandait de guimbarde
pour 10 quant
aux moyens spectacle
quelle mouche l'oeil
[Applaudissements]
je peux dire que je m'attendais pas à ça
tous les accrochages sur la route
font que la vie vaut la peine d'être
vécue
par ta jamais
j'adore les dinos mobile chez patron
s'il te plaît tu as choisi nos trois
derniers arrêts le plus grand labyrinthe
de ceux du monde partage
[Musique]